welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars and or episode 10 one way out maybe
the most riveted I have felt watching
Star Wars since the trench run or maybe
since the ending of Rogue one they're
both pretty great now yes again I do
look and sound different I just happen
to be in the new rockstars HQ office on
Wednesdays we'll be back to your regular
looking me next video so bear with me
but hey with this episode if I have to
get on the intercom of your workplace
prisons to shout the reasons this show
is great I will do it lots of great
little details in this masterpiece of an
episode so let us break it all down the
opening music for this episode strips
out all the anxious percussion that
we've heard in past episode intros and
really just returns to Hopeful hopeful
strings
then we open on poor Olaf being zipped
into a body bag the curved zipper has
this odd look to it kind of like a pouch
for food it just wouldn't surprise me if
this is a Soylent Green scenario and
those meat hoses that they suckle from
as dead prisoners after playing the thug
who set up Michael Keaton to say hi
Batman and basically the Lutheran rail
of zandar and Guardians of the Galaxy
Chris Fairbanks really has another
iconic role for the books his Gurney
hovers through the level as they all
wait on program which almost takes on
the tone of a funeral procession with
all of them standing in respect Cassian
tells Kino Loy with to go tomorrow
tomorrow you heard me
go away
anyway it has to be tomorrow
this repetition of the word tomorrow
invokes the famous line from
Shakespeare's Macbeth tomorrow and
tomorrow and tomorrow Creeps in this
Petty Pace from day to day to the last
syllable of recorded time and all our
yesterdays have lighted fools the way to
Dusty death out out brief candle life's
but a walking Shadow a poor player that
struts and Frets his hour upon the stage
and then is heard no more it is a tale
told by an idiot full of sound and puree
signifying nothing this is what Macbeth
says after learning of his wife's death
he's expressing the futility of life and
how all of our actions really amount to
nothing in the grand scheme of things
his words not mine but this is how
kinoloi might feel in this moment after
losing his beloved Uli all his toiling
signify nothing a tale told by an idiot
Kino says the guards still have power
but Cassie encounters power
power doesn't panic Cassian had seen
Imperial crackdowns before and he knows
most of the time it's done as an
afterthought but an overreaction
indicates Panic which indicates
surrender power Kino says on program to
Cassie at the beginning of the scene and
when Cassian tells him that the plan
centers around the new prisoner transfer
Kino freezes in his tracks and the scene
ends with Cassian telling Kino on
program it's a perfect illustration of
this idea of power doesn't panic Cassian
ends his scene less Panic than Kino Kino
has surrendered some power over to
Cassian now Cassian lingers on the floor
miles
we will be activating floors without
warning Chief more
yeah the announcer's voice is credited
in the credits as voice of God and it's
actually a long time lucasfilm casket
associate Martin Ware we actually see
this actor later in the control room now
thanks to vesi for sponsoring this video
I'm obviously detail obsessed if there's
one thing driving me nuts about Andor
it's what's everyone wearing
if it were me and if I were trying to
foment a galactic Rebellion against a
well-armed foe I wouldn't want to have
to think about whether or not my socks
were wet Rebels don't have time to dodge
puddles so they probably wear vessies
that way they don't have to think about
it Bessie is here to keep you looking
good while keeping your feet dry yes
these are the perfect everyday shoe they
are sustainably made knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof they are made with a
dime a text material that's super easy
to clean with just a rinse of water oh
no I spilled water all over my feetsy
Wheaties but my Oinky oinkies are blown
dry like the Dune seeds
if the weather is wet or if it's muddy
vessies can help you vesties are my
go-to shoes that are right by my door
check them out in the link below for a
pair of your own Vesti shoes Cassian
Waits until the last possible second to
clear that floor before the current
switches on really he does this to steal
everyone's attention and focus it on
what he and Kino have learned about
Oola's death and Kino finally confirms
it no one is getting out
foreign
bass notes here to Mark the Dark Truth
hitting them all with a thud Rivera
reports their plan of using a rebel ship
as bait to lure in the rebel into
Krieger and how it is working pilot dead
ship adrift Port of origin unknown
Catherine rescue Salvage reports
unresponsive gpe 7000 operator appears
to have Frozen following hydraulic
failure on hyperspace re-entry yeah they
are review doing a report from khafreen
the rings of caprene being the location
in Rogue one this is reporting the
captured rebel pilot who's now
apparently dead on the ship behind Dedra
notice that oramesh translates to fand
and caffreen fan is the name of the
sector where caprine is located she
hands Party Guys the tablet but he
doesn't take it and instead he takes
Lonnie Young's advice to check out the
ship so Krieger doesn't get suspicious
Dedra suspects something is up and we
stay on young setting up that there's
more going on with this guy Cassian
watches his day clock shift from 2156 to
2155 like someone who woke up too early
watching their alarm clock go from 6 59
to 7 A.M Kino declares we are done
with counting shifts
there is only then
and now
there is only one way out
play it how you won
but I'm gonna assume I'm already dead
and take it from there yes no more
counting shifts only then and now a
powerful rejection of the way the Empire
tries to control time itself in a
paradigm shift to reject the past and
embrace the present and he says assume
you're dead because under the Empire
stasis equals Death similarly Lutheran
considers himself dead meanwhile on
ferricks Jesse brings in Dr momoy
because Marva is not taking her pills
and since it takes note of this korv
also keeps an eye on this he was one of
dedra's Imperial officers Davos scalden
meets with Monmouth he's the banker that
tay brought up last episode to help out
man with a loan so that she can move her
money around more freely mon talks about
her home it's State Property the rules
are strict on Decor our choices for
change are limited yeah the Empire even
has rules over how much senators are
allowed to decorate their homes davo
brings up man's husband and says
chandrillen arranged marriages benefit
from what he calls Clarity boundaries
can be liberating they always have value
he is teasing but he'll eventually ask
Vermon but he's also consenting his
overall approval to the boundaries being
drawn by the Empire across the Galaxy
Davos since it's not just money for a
charitable Foundation He suggests that
his fee will actually be to introduce
his 14 year old son to her 13 year old
daughter and suddenly it's Game of
Thrones shuts that [ __ ] down it's a lot
to think about I'm not thinking about it
that's the first untrue thing you've
said yeah it's come up a few times on
the series that our inner thoughts are
the one place the Empire can't get to us
so davo telling mon what she is thinking
in this moment feels especially
pervasive Clea tells luthin that a spy
has made contact by marking a fountain
and removing a rail this whole chat
between them is done in a single take
and while it's not the flashy kind of
wonder that calls attention to itself it
is the kind of thing that this series
does to ground Us in moments with
characters like in cassian's opening
argument with Keno we stay a long time
on any circus before we cut Luther
publishes that Naboo headdress that we
saw Padme wearing an attack at the
clones and in the back of the shop
Lutheran has moved the Jedi holocron to
be closer to Indiana Jones Carbonite
rack I really think no one actually buys
anything in the shop they just move
things around and make it look like it's
a real business a target's hand trembles
as he loses his nerve and Cassian gets a
tool handed off to him and he returns to
that bathroom to keep sawing at that
pipe as Kino plays his part and Barks at
the room for being behind we cut to the
guards upstairs we have a check on three
do that now we're already behind yeah
the guards are also constantly
scrambling terrified of falling behind
on their tasks Cassian prize to open the
water pipe to flood the bathroom and the
men on the floor go on program each of
them tucking tools and heavy Parts
behind their heads Cassian joins the
others a bit late soaking wet and the
guards don't even notice now there's a
recurring theme with cassian's wetness
on the show and the opening scene in the
series he was soaked in rain and the
Primo guards actually made jokes about
him swimming over which one could argue
probably was a bit of coded racism there
and I bring this up because I
specifically talk about qunari having
dark features which does seem to
correspond with Diego Luna's race Dedra
talked about casting her net to catch
fish last episode also the name given to
prisoners their first night in prison
and now in this episode Cassian gets to
Freedom by swimming here it's like the
guards are so used to seeing their
inmates covered in sweat from being
nervous or from working that they don't
even notice a guy soaked head to toe in
water the plan begins with him and zal
the most naturally angry looking inmates
fake in a fight like those Brothers in
Ocean's 11 Cassian jams the lift the new
prisoner being brought in instinctively
Springs to action and zaps the warden
given his own life because he is the
first to get shot actually part of what
makes this prison escape so gripping is
how many inmates we see die like I hated
seeing Bernard get blasted when he was
hanging from that platform the whole
thing is just messy like the Rogue one
Vader kill box sequence it's not a swift
Victorious exit it's a scramble it's a
costly rugby try the guards use Imperial
Blaster pistols just like the weapons
used by the crew on the Tanta IV and A
New Hope throughout this opening volley
notice keynote plants right near the
shock box on the floor knowing that the
water will reach it and that someone
down there will need to be standing
there for the guards to spark the floor
which is how they Short Circuit the
whole floor remembering that the wiring
of this place is pretty weak when the
lights glicker last episode the loss
it's just continue to pile up and sting
but this episode does a really good job
pinging back and forth between losses
and wins to keep us engaged like Zoll
goes down which really sucks but
immediately after Cassian makes it up to
the higher level kicks a leg punches
dude's mouth and pulls off an impressive
double play by using that guy's Blaster
to take out another from an impressively
low angle so now the room is secure you
can actually argue it's because it's all
distracted that first guard by throwing
the tool at him that gave Cassie in the
window enough time to knock him down and
grab his Blaster see every sacrifice
counts Kino yells at them to climb which
is also what mimics screamed to Cassian
in episode 6 and k2so's last word to
Cassian in Rogue one now one thing that
surprised me about all this is how none
of these inmates ever strap on those
boots to protect themselves in case the
guards ever tried to spark the floors
but I guess they covered that by short
circuiting one sector and overall really
speed and stealth are more crucial it's
really a foot race to get to the central
control room like notice how they first
go for The Blasters instead of the boots
which is actually pretty smart because
Cassian hears those same clunky boots
coming around the corner and gets a drop
on them Cassian urges Kino forward
yeah another smart move because cassia
knows that Kino is the elder most voice
among them and he recognized that Kino's
real value is to put that deep smoky
voice on the PA to call all levels to
Riot so Cassian tosses a gun to ham to
implicitly put him in charge of holding
this level I also love how this episode
cuts to the point of view of workers
initially detaching the riot and we see
the moment that they get conscripted
yeah ham is going ham the voice of God
we learn is modulated to make this
younger guard sound even more
intimidating any deviation or failure to
comply will result in unit-wide
activation start the count yeah Imperial
power is a total illusion casting as big
of a shadow as possible in this card
again credited as voice of God has the
Vengeance and Wrath of an Old Testament
variety five five five three five six
burn a firewall around it try the whole
level make the episodes of five two too
late
there's nobody there voice of God was
ready to electrocute 700 men you'll see
that their screens show floor plans of
every level with glowing yellow dots for
each inmate this younger control officer
is credited as apostle as he blindly
follows the voice of God's lead behind
him you can see numbers for each level
kind of like open spots in a freaking
parking garage one reads 686 another 504
meaning one level has lost 14 inmates
another 196 maybe that was level two who
was already down 100. Cassian tells the
possible to cut the power caught the
power so Hydro
once we turn it off it takes months to
get it back up and running again yeah so
that explains us whirlpools surrounding
the facility these are apparently
turbines that generate the hydroelectric
power Cassian tells Kino to speak to all
the inmates over the PA and notice that
microphone is the same two-cylinder
design as a microphone that Han Solo
speaks into in the Death Star right
before he shoots the panel Chino is
nervous but he begins my name
is
shift manager on level five yeah with
Andy circus's voice modulated down he
really does sound a lot more like snow
Cassian urges him to put some elbow
grease into this how long we hang on
how far we get
how many of us make it out all of that
is now
up to us and behind Kino you can
actually see some of those inmates on
one level starting to get motivated as
they move toward the door and Kino finds
his inner strength we will never have a
better chance than this
and I would rather die trying to take
them down and giving them what they want
yeah he actually quotes these same words
Cassian spoke to him earlier and it
could feel nemic sentiments flowing
through Cassian and then flowing into
the most powerful voice of the three
this is what a rebellion sounds like
Kino says there is one way out right now
building is us
you need to run climb kill
you need to help each other
you see someone who's confused some
someone's lost
if you get them moving and you keep them
moving until we put this place behind us
an incredible Call to Arms ironically it
was Kino's barking at workers to help
each other fill Parts quotas that he can
now weaponize as an instrument of
Destruction against the empire Kino gets
into chant the rallying Cry of one way
out which he continues to shout even
after stepping away from the microphone
all right
[Music]
guards cower in absolute fear as the
inmate storm passed and I just love the
amount of sweat they coated on the guard
closest to us the inmates taste the
fresh air and ham doesn't even wait he
Leroy Jenkins right over the edge so
that they all tumble into the water like
Lemmings Cassian turns to melshi his
future partner from Rogue one
yeah you can definitely feel the
beginning of a valuable friendship
forming between these two that's why the
episode ends with these two sticking
together sprinting through the ashy
Fields toward the light of three moons
but poor Kino doesn't make it
at first it feels like a personal defeat
for Kino but you can see a bit of pride
in his eyes as he watches the others
dive into the water and swim to Freedom
kind of like the other patients in the
facility and One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest cheering his chief breaks out
neither Kino nor Lutheran will see the
promised land and we cut to a high
overhead shot of the seventh-sided
facility which makes us a little nervous
because this is a point of view of the
facility one would see from the Death
Star the battle station these facilities
are likely supplying parts for on
Coruscant we follow young to an elevator
where he finds a hidden ear pierce with
Lutheran's voice we'll have privacy
running Express yeah we stay
uninterrupted with young for long
stretches but now there are real-time
jump cuts to slightly different angles
of young space creating the slightly
disorienting effect in the elevator
young boy's Lutheran about dead Ramiro
and how they're using Anto Krieger's
pilot as a trap believe that plans to
just let the mission go forward to keep
the Empire from knowing there's a leak
at all
50 men
you're worth more than that you have to
warn them yes 50 men exactly the number
of men working in an arena 5 12-hour
shift luthin exhibits a parallel
ruthlessness the elevator suddenly opens
up on Lutheran down on floor 331 meaning
this is hundreds of layers deep in the
course on underworld Lutheran's cloak
Billows making him look super Sinister
you notice Lutheran is out of his
antique steel or costume because despite
his trust for young he still doesn't
want young to see his alter ego like Leo
in The Departed young wants out because
he's a daddy now but Luton says we took
a vow presumably the same bow that Bell
in Monmouth were talking about last
episode young asks Lupine what he
sacrificed teeing up Stellan Skarsgard
to give an incredible monologue calm
kindness kinship
love
I've given up a little chance at inner
peace I made my mind a sunless face
I share my dreams with ghosts the ghosts
of whom we wonder Rebels he sacrificed
maybe a loved one again we come back to
Macbeth who shares his dinners with the
ghost of banquil Lutheran goes on I wake
up every day to an equation I wrote 15
years ago from which there's only one
conclusion
I'm damned for what I do I yearn to be a
savior against Injustice without
contemplating the cost and by the time I
looked down
I was no longer any ground beneath my
feet an equation he wrote 15 years ago
sounds like Lutheran was once a
Manifesto writer a lot like nemic really
Luth and his who nemic might have grown
up to be he considers himself damned
much like Paul Newman's character in
Road to Perdition and there is only
one guarantee none of us will see heaven
and Lutheran finishes with what is My
Sacrifice
I'm condemned to use the tools of my
enemy
to defeat them I burned my decency for
someone else's future I burned my life
to make a sunrise that I know I'll Never
See
now the ego that started this fight will
never have a
mirror or an audience or the light of
gratitude
so what do I sacrifice
everything
that echo on the end of the word
everything immortalizes Luther's anguish
it'd be one thing for a rebel to lose
his soul and just not have the words to
describe it but Lutheran's true curse is
self-awareness in a poet's mind that
accurately describe how dead he feels
normally in Star Wars breakdowns I
compare dialogues to like past moments
because so much of Star Wars on Disney
plus is just pure crack Nostalgia it's
like poetry it Rhymes but this folks is
poetry a truly original haunting Insight
this is the moment other future Star
Wars titles will be compared to you can
follow me on Tick Tock Instagram and
Twitter at EA boss follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new Rockstar some more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]